There are
the beginnings of an intellectual
revulsion at,
at what conservatives,
what has been done to conservatism as a
governing philosophy in America.
Um,
and I think one of the roles of the day,
the dishes now trying to,
to play is to be a place where those
voices can be,
can be brought to a wider audience.
So I think of Bruce Bartlett who along
with me in the early part of the Bush
administration,
called them out on that fiscal
irresponsibility is a voice that I'm
very happy to,
to,
to keep bringing.
I think a much later,
someone like David Frum has come to that
recognition even though I think we're
still going to disagree about foreign
policy.
I think,
um,
there are some libertarian voices that
are out there.
Um,
and I think a younger generation of
reasoned people I think of,
I think of people like Damon linker.
Um,
uh,
there are,
there are people out there.
Uh,
unfortunately what's happened in
Washington and more generally is that
the conservative movement is bankrolled
by certain large donors and with certain
overwhelming interests.
Um,
and they police the discourse with a
ferocity and a lockstep mentality that
has frozen conservatism as a,
as a,
as a philosophy in place.
Um,
and turned it into an ideology that kind
of ever change,
um,
or Alijah it with such fundamentalist
concepts that there can be no real
conservative dialogue because dialogue
is not what fundamentalism is about.
Uh,
and the price of lip simply existing as
a,
a conservative in Washington to be in
good standing is to obey the dictates of
whichever this constellation of donors
and organizations from heritage to Aei,
um,
to even something like pajamas media,
which is apparently financed by people
who are also financing West Bank
settlements.
Um,
is if,
if you stray,
you are expelled.
And then also thoroughly demonized.
So intellectually we are,
you know,
the blogosphere allows these kinds of
ideas to percolate and I mean kind of
Fritos door for example,
is a young conservative,
uh,
whom I've brought on specifically with
the mandate of because find and courage
let us bring to light young writers
right of center who are not yet,
have not been yet basically bought by
this establishment.
And then coerced to certain positions.
Daniel Larson is another person.
Now these people don't normally agree by
any means.
That's the point.
I mean,
but they do not,
they,
they have acknowledged that conservatism
in the past 10,
15,
20 years.
It's not that there was a great period
of pure,
great conservatives and we've never had
this,
some of these populist,
xenophobic,
racist,
bigoted strains.
It's that that was always there.
Um,
it is that there was also a lot of good
stuff there that we were responding to
contingent situations such as the
collapse of the social democracy model
in the 1970s and a really smart critique
of the welfare state.
And a really,
I think,
critical insight into how one defeats
solving communism.
What's,
what's happened is that all that stuff
has slowly been marginalized and well,
the worst has come to the surface.
Um,
and that,
that won't change overnight.
And I think from everything we're seeing
talk radio and,
uh,
these,
I think essentially corrupting
institutions in Washington are turning
conservatism into something that really
very creepy,
but also emotionally and psychically
powerful for people.
So all you do is all you can do is is
write books,
write articles,
write blogs that articulate
what you believe.